[Music]
sounds like
work no tell them i'm in my chair
yes he's just walked in this is
unexpected
i can't believe i'm actually having
lunch with spies
i'm just a salesman exactly you're
civilians of the kgb won't be watching
it would be a real service to great
britain
what would you want me to do
i'm here to open a door to the
top manufacturers in the west
will i be putting myself in danger if
this mission was the least bit dangerous
you really are the last man we'd send
make sure you wear it while you're in
moscow
what does this do shoot poison dart
everyone you meet assume their kgb
every russian is an eye of the state it
will just be a career just a career for
russian
from now on you will be selling one
thing the idea that you are an
ordinary businessman and nothing more
than an ordinary businessman
the weapons of war must be abolished
before they apologize
i'm asking you to stop going to moscow i
am asking you as your wife
i want you to be involved
if i get caught then execute be correct
we can't get him out if things were the
other way around and cops would abandon
you he would never
leave me to die and i'm not leaving him
i'm volunteering to bring back the best
source of servant intelligence you've
got at a time where russia and america
are on the brink of nuclear war
[Applause]
maybe we're only two people
but this is how things change
[Music]
you